good morning believe nation today's
message is love and hate it over to you
Christian Bale is there a reason that
you get out of bed to go act every what
you do because when it's good it's
really good then when it's not can ate
it you know but when it's good it's it's
it's a love-hate thing and it's a
love/hate thing for me because of coming
from a place where it was actually a
responsibility a young age because you
know for my family was just such an
unfathomable amount of sudden cash that
you could get for doing it that I went
yeah well even I don't really feel like
doing it I can't really live with myself
for not because it helps my family so
much you know and so I felt
responsibility to do that
so I come at it from a slightly
different point of view you know it
wasn't something that I said I went
through school car no you know I'd like
to become an actor oh yeah I loved films
I like that's what I'm gonna try to do
it was something that happened at an
early age and then I went I can't get
out of this because it's really helpful
to a family you know and so ya know I
must do it so that's why I've got this
like love/hate thing with it but I
actually think the love-hate is quite a
healthy thing to have if all you do is
love film if what you do is love acting
you're just gonna imitate what you love
right it takes people to hate it at the
same time to make any sort of change to
what they're doing you know and to me
that's when you know it becomes
interesting what resonated most with me
from this clip was the idea that the
change happens when you hate something
it can be a very powerful force for good
hate forces you to change something when
I was young and just getting out of
university I wanted to do exciting
meaningful big work that's what I loved
what I hated having a work inside a
company and so I became an entrepreneur
I loved building a team and having
people to work around me but I hated the
hiring process a traditional hiring
process so I changed it with my YouTube
channel I love online videos and
learning and I wanted to surround myself
with all these great ideas and people
and I hated how was currently being
delivered like nobody was aggregating
the videos together so that's what led
to the top ten series in this an
espresso series so I had a love for
something and I hated how it was
currently being done and so I changed it
and found the opportunity were you know
hate is often seen as a negative thing
it strives you to want to make a change
the real enemy isn't hate the real enemy
is good if you love something and
everything is just good for you you're
never gonna strive to be great because
it's still good because you're still
enjoying it because it's not frustrating
there's nothing that makes you want to
change something where if you love
something and you hate the way it's
currently being done you're gonna change
it right you're gonna find another way
to do it because this way is
unacceptable I will not stand for it
anymore I must change it when it's good
you just let it slide by think of all
the good things in your life how many
times have you wanted to make a change
for it you don't because you focus on
the things that aren't going well and
how can I make those much better good is
the enemy of great hate is not the enemy
of great hate lets you build something
great if you love it so the questions of
eight today is I'm curious what do you
love and hate leave it in the comments
below and I'll join the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events press